[Music]  it's time for et's social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online I can't help it Jennifer Lopez  shared this uncanny snap to Instagram of  her eight-year-old daughter Emmy with  boyfriend Alex Rodriguez's look like  daughter Natasha these two could be  twins on a ferris posted several  hilarious pics to Twitter of the  step-by-step process to get ready for  hubby Chris Pratt's guardians of the  galaxy to premiere in Los Angeles  checking out her shirtless man in the  mirror while beautifying himself  check out those under eye masks writing  now it's getting real Chris may be  annoyed I'm a little nervous  bella thorne isn't nervous or shy about  flaunting her bod the famous and love  star snapped to risque selfies in this  see-through lace ensemble showing off  some new hardware nipple rings  [Music]